[Musique]
bonjour rex est jo merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes le député des
alpes-maritimes vous êtes un peu le
monsieur sécurité des républicains hier
christophe castaner qui disaient nos
forces de l'ordre ont permis d'éviter la
catastrophe est ce que c'est juste
les forces de l'ordre ont été une
nouvelle fois exemplaire
elles le sont depuis plusieurs mois
j'allais dire elles le sont depuis
depuis toujours elles font aujourd'hui
face à de multiples menaces ailière
encore il y avait beaucoup de forces de
l'ordre mobilisées 7200 l onf à la
violence mais la violence
elle est toujours là et quand j'entends
ce matin les messages d'auto
satisfaction du ministre de l'intérieur
je regarde quand même la situation il y
a eu lieu hier 38 blessés dont 14
policiers janvier parce que là je
comprends bien c'est commencer par dire
les forces de l'ordre ont été
irréprochables mais par contre le milieu
intérieur lui ne le serait pas la
situation perdure ça fait six mois qu'il
y à de la violence de l'ultra violence
dans la rue hier les manifestations en
tous cas à paris n'ont pas pu se
dérouler normalement le message des
syndicats avec une forte mobilisation a
été une fois de plus entravée par la
violence alors on nous dira c'est moins
pire que ce qu'on avait dit mais moi je
ne me réjouis pas de cette situation qui
voit deux commissariats attaqués un
hôpital attaques et des blessés un crs
grièvement blessé par le jet d'un pavé
donc ce n'est pas circulez ya rien à
voir ça s'est bien passé non ça ne s'est
pas bien passé et moi je dis aujourd'hui
qu'il faut changer de dimension face à
la violence pardon mais on était quand
même au plafond vous le disiez vous même
de très nombreux policiers présents 7400
forces de l'ordre 100 90 motos et drones
est-ce que c'était suffisant est ce
qu'il aurait fallu faire plus non bien
entendu le calibrage des moyens étaient
très importants et il a permis de faire
face à l'ultra violence il y avait un
millier
black box etc le problème et je vais y
revenir qui était présent dans la
manifestation
mais on ne pourra pas éternellement
mettre cette pression sur les policiers
vous savez depuis plusieurs mois les
policiers ne pouvaient le peuvent
quasiment plus près d'un week end ne
prennent plus des vacances qui sont sur
pression ils sont avec des contraintes
extrêmement lourdes et ça il faut en
tenir compte que ça soit la pression de
la violence dans la rue que ça soit la
menace terroriste ne l'oublions pas qui
est encore là que ça soit la pression
migratoire donc les policiers les
gendarmes les forces de l'ordre
subissent on leur demande beaucoup et
ils ne pourront pas éternellement
l'autre réponse est les préalables
parce que quand on fait face à cette
violence dans la rue sait déjà qu'on a
échoué
préalablement au jour réglementer les
jours qui précèdent c'est l'organisation
c'est la police et les jours c'est les
semaines c'est l'émoi ona laisser
s'installer la violence dans notre pays
on a baissé la garde
ona donner moins de valeur à la notion
d'autorité quand on a cédé aux
extrémistes violents à notre dame des
landes
on a lancé un message aussi le persuade
le trio originel en quelque soit fait
partie de ces signaux méliane il y en a
d'autres
c'est bien préalable à ce gouvernement
il faut le reconnaître
aussi on a cette idéologie qui a laissé
quelque part prospéré depuis nuit debout
la violence d'extrême gauche
les blagues et exemple si aujourd'hui
juste une poche fait une opposition très
très plaisir il faut qu'il y ait une
réponse judiciaire massive et préalable
les black box se sont une association de
malfaiteurs se sont une insulte à sion
au sens du code pénal c'est une
association de malfaiteurs il s'entraîne
de façon clandestine
ils sont armés ils ont des visées
violente c'est même quelque part une
association de malfaiteurs à visée
terroriste parce que quand on veut
déstabiliser les institutions de la
république
c'est une forme de terrorisme ont fait
donc il
jean aicard ocde judiciaire mais avec
des enquêtes massy vous savez sur
d'autres enquêtes dans d'autres domaines
on a mobilisé des dizaines d'enquêteurs
plusieurs juges d'instruction
donc aujourd'hui il faut qu'on s'attaque
à ce noyau il y à 1000 à 2000 black
blocks dans notre pays ils sont
identifiés ils sont comme ça il faut non
il faut pas changer le code pénal il ya
tous les outils il faut simplement avoir
la volonté que le garde des sceaux
demande aujourd'hui qu'il y ait une
priorité de politique pénale pour
s'attaquer à ces groupuscules
il faut qu'ils aient l'information
judiciaire qui soit ouverte cet opus est
le pari de prendre ses responsabilités
il y à déjà d une multitude enquête il
ya des comparutions immédiates il y à
des sanctions
je ne conteste pas mais il faut changer
qu'est-ce que j'ai changé d'échelle
savez il faut qu'on le fasse
préalablement que ces personnes soient
interpellés qu'elle soit jugée parce que
aujourd'hui c'est une entreprise de
l'extrême gauche de déstabilisation de
la société et le gouvernement
là-dessus n'assume pas ses
responsabilités
il est incapable depuis six mois la
violence et dans la rue depuis six mois
combien ça va durer des policiers une
interview au magazine the tea j'ai
l'impression que en fait vous ne faites
des réponses qui aurait pu avoir lieu il
ya trois mois il ya quand même des
choses qui ont évolué et vous votre
logiciel vos réponses sont toujours les
mêmes c'est que y'a du laxisme et on a
quand même l'impression que la stratégie
a évolué et qui a des résultats quinté
obtenu - je crois que c'est tu déjà une
défaite intellectuelle de dire on se
réjouit de ce qui s'est passé hier
non moi je ne me réjouis pas je vous le
redis de ces scènes de violence pour
autant se réjouit le commissariat thrill
sont laxistes
ce commissariat forcément carrière je ne
dis pas qu'ils sont laxistes jeudi que
la politique vous avez prononcé les mots
une réponse judiciaire qui est mise en
oeuvre n'est pas à la hauteur du défi
qu'est l'ancienne donc on fait quoi on
fait monter les enchères on va on va
jusqu'où guizot seconde dissolution des
groupuscules d'extrême gauche
réponse judiciaire beaucoup plus ferme
et puis globalement globalement
meilleure protection des policiers
il faut aujourd'hui que ceux qui
touchent un policier ceux qui lancent un
pavé contre un policier
ceux qui m'aiment profère une insulte
contre un représentant de l'autorité
publique ils soient policiers gendarmes
sapeurs-pompiers qui sont aussi victimes
subissent des sanctions très lourdes
dissuasive moi je crois à la capacité
dissuasive de la sanction
les policiers qui font un travail
formidable et je veux leur rendre
hommage
eh bien ils sont en dernière ligne c'est
avant qu'on gagne ce travail c'est un
changement radical de deux méthodes de
politique il faut réinstaller de la
fermeté contre la délinquance il y à la
délinquance de rue mais savait depuis
quelques mois on constate une
augmentation des coups et blessures dans
notre pays de 11 pour 7 ils sont en
train de tout mettre dans le même sac
lui bah oui tout le bruit ou dans le
même sac oui c'est à dire qu'il faut une
réponse contre la violence toutes les
formes de violence qu'elle soit dans la
rue qu'elle soit gratuite qu'elle soit
contre les symboles de l'autorité et il
faut lutter contre la violence et pour
cela il faut restaurer l'autorité alors
maintenant gérer quand même juste qu'on
en vienne au fait de ce qui s'est passé
hier et je voudrais comprendre vous
dites il était suffisamment nombreux la
réponse des forces de l'ordre a été la
bonne et pourtant vous dites ça ne va
pas qu'est ce que vous vous auriez fait
de mieux je pensais que vous vous
aimeriez bien être mise à l'arrière vous
auriez et au manager vous auriez fait
quand je crois ne pas avoir réussi à
bien comprendre je comprends pas vous
dites au fond
la réponse était plutôt proportionnée
mais en même temps ça ne va pas on est
un constat il y a eu des violences hier
en partie moi je commissariat du xiiie
amber pitié salpêtrière et rien c'est
c'est des images très chaud comme un
policier grièvement blessé il va être
opéré ce matin et je pense à lui je
pense à ses collègues
donc aujourd'hui il faut que dans notre
société on considère la sécurité la
protection des français comme une
priorité nationale depuis trop longtemps
on a baissé la garde
on a affaibli notre réponse pénale on a
diminué les sanctions qui devait
dissuader la violence la délinquance est
quelque part aujourd'hui on en paye le
prix on a lancé des messages de
faiblesse notre dame des landes nuit
debout depuis des mois depuis peut-être
des années j'en conviens donc il faut
aujourd'hui que la protection des
princes des français devienne une
priorité je reviendrai juste vous
reposer une question parce qu'on n'y
avait pas vraiment répondu tout cela sur
ce constat on est bien d'accord mais est
ce que vous estimez quand même que
depuis quelques semaines il ya eu un
changement dans la réponse du
gouvernement
il ya eu une adaptation il ya des
changements c'est mieux il ya eu des
changements permanents
on verra bien sûr le sur le long terme
depuis le début le gouvernement a changé
quatre ou cinq fois de doctrine
mais ce qui change en fait ce sont les
effectifs qui sont mobilisés
essentiellement pour refuser absolument
mais mahut s'est les plus faibles les
plus violentes c'est parce qu'on avait
baissé la garde en début d'année le
gouvernement à baisser la garde
hier il a remonté il a eu raison
naturellement de le faire
ce que je dis c'est qu'on ne peut pas
éternellement demandé avec les mêmes
moyens sans augmenter les moyens les
revient cette répulsion penan aux
policiers et aux récessions des moyens
budgétaires
il ya une question de réponse pénale et
on ne fera pas l'économie de ces débats
dans nos sur le fond les manifestants
étaient malgré tout nombreux est-ce que
les syndicats sont dépassés est-ce qu'il
faut inventer de nouvelles façons
d'exprimer leurs revendications
ou est-ce qu'il faut quand même que les
manifestations puissent continuer à
avoir lieu moi je pense que dans une
démocratie
les syndicats ont naturellement leur
place leur discours s'est affaibli au
cours des années écoulées parce qu'ils
se sont il faut bien le reconnaître et
notamment la cgt
enfermé dans un discours très
caricatural très éloignée de la réalité
des évolutions sociales et économiques
du pays mais il ne faut pas rompre ce
dialogue
emmanuel macron au début à ignorer
totalement tout ce qui peut être
assimilé les responsabilités dans
l'affaiblissement il a une
responsabilité dans la situation du pays
dans les tensions sociales le fait qu'
il y aujourd'hui cette colère dans la
rue qu'il y ait cette violence qu'il y
ait ce malaise quel est le bilan depuis
deux ans bien sûr qu'il a une immense
responsabilité
il a été élu avec l'image du rassembleur
celui qui devait piocher sur les deux
rives pour choisir les meilleurs et pour
établir la meilleure politique ça
c'était l'espérance moi je n'y ai jamais
cru personnellement mais certains n'ont
plus des français de très bonne foi
longs blonds soutenu pour cela
aujourd'hui le bilan en est à quelques
jours du deuxième anniversaire de
l'élection de monsieur macro il faut
dire que tous les paramètres sont
aujourd'hui dégradé le chômage qui est
quand même le coeur du malaise social de
beaucoup de gains un début de baisse de
famille
oui mais si on compare à nos partenaires
européens ces deux points de plus que
tous les pays de l' de l'union
européenne c'est un point de plus de la
zone euro comme nicolas sarkozy a quitté
le pouvoir en 2012 le chômage étaient
deux points inférieure en france à la
moyenne de la zone euro celle inverse
aujourd'hui donc quand on se compare on
cite des chiffres en zambie ça va mieux
mais ça va beaucoup plus mal que de tous
nos partenaires européens on a le record
des déficits européens
on a quasiment le record de la dette
on est très mal placé sur le chômage on
alors
record du monde des impôts voilà la
situation aujourd'hui et en plus on à la
violence
c'est cette situation que les fixer dans
la rue vous avez entendu les
déclarations d' emmanuel macron la
semaine dernière et il a eu cette
expression c'est un véritable chapitres
entiers de sa politique désormais
reconstruire l'art d'être français son
nouveau combat ça vous parle
moi j'ai envie de dire à monsieur macron
qu'il faut arrêter avec ces slogans avec
ses mots avec cette outrance mais quand
ça ne veut pas toujours dire nous ce qui
irait dans notre sens
et moi je suis prêt à prouver toutes les
mesures qui vont dans la bonne direction
dans l'intérêt du pays
ce sont des actes mais quand il augmente
les impôts de façon inconsidérée depuis
deux ans lorsqu'il fait peser sur les
retraités un fardeau insupportable et un
juge est la suivante remercier eric
ciotti mais là encore j'ai envie de dire
je vais adapter votre discours quand
même il ya des choses qui se passent il
ne va pas baisser
il a dans un premier temps décidé une
augmentation massive de la pression sur
les retraités 20% d'augmentation de la
cg non indexation des pensions de
retraite sur l'inflation
et puis au bout d'un certain temps face
à la colère edit ah ben on mettra pas en
place ces augmentations ou ces
prélèvements mais est ce que les
retraités vont gagner plus
pas du tout par rapport à la situation
de 2017
il va verser un minimum pour les
retraites avant l'euro c'est quand même
une drôle de méthode aujourd'hui de dire
dans un premier temps ge annoncent une
forte augmentation
elle crée de la colère et puis je là je
la relève je la retire et j'ai dit oh la
la c'est formidable non mais l'ado en
dessus sur les questions économiques et
liqueurs de la colère il faut pas
l'oublier bien sûr la violence elle se
réglera on a parlé des réponses pénales
elle se réglera aussi avec une
amélioration de la situation économique
et sociale de notre pays ce qui est très
fragile et que je dis c'est que pour une
fois que effectivement emmanuel macron
ouvre un chantier qui globalement on le
sent bien et plutôt convergence de vue
avec le vôtre ça vous dit que c'est pas
important reconstruire l'art d'être
français c'est pas important ça veut
dire quoi reconstruire leurs dates
france et j'allais vous poser la
question voilà ça veut dire
diminuer l'immigration alors que depuis
un débat à l'assemblée nationale ça fait
partie des propositions souper non c'est
pas la même chose annan a soupé des
débats ce qu'on demandait avec françois
fillon c'est un vote avec retard des
quotas migratoires là ça va être du
blabla comme le grand débat comme les
commissions qui sortent de la conclusion
du grand débat comme les citoyennes
tirés au sort tout ça c'est de la
communication la reine français ils
seront l'islamisme politique
j'allais venir pour moi l'art d'être
français c'est diminuer voire
aujourd'hui radicalement diminuer
l'immigration
on a battu le record des titres de
séjour donné l'année dernière 262000 on
a battu le nombre de demandeurs d'asile
122000 de demandeurs d'asile
enfin sa personne n'y est pour rien de
demandeurs d'asile on n'a pas battu le
record d'acceptation de l'asie si
puisqu'on est quasiment à aujourd'hui à
quasiment car plus de 40000 statut de
réfugié qui a été octroyé ça veut dire
que chaque année rentrer dans notre pays
quasiment 400 mille étrangers en
situation légale
sans parler des étrangers en situation
illégale parlons de la radicalisation
qu'est ce qui est fait aujourd'hui pour
expulser les quatre mille étrangers bien
4000 qui sont inscrits au ffs pertes et
le fichier des signalé pour la
radicalisation terroristes qui sont
étrangers qui présentent une menace pour
la france et qui sont toujours là j'ai
réclamé à plusieurs reprises à
l'assemblée nationale là dessus rien n'a
bougé que fait-on pour fermer les 100
mosquées salafistes
on nous dit que cette divinité est
refermé les lieux vous l'avez vu la
semaine dernière jean michel blanquer le
ministre de l'éducation qui avait dit
qu'il demandait la fermeture d'une école
à echirolles dont il disait qu'elle
était d'inspiration salafiste il avait
cette fermeture a été confirmée ensuite
par le tribunal
et pourtant non seulement cette école
est toujours ouverte à l'heure où on se
parle mais elle porte plainte contre
jean-michel blanquer qui est à leurs
yeux coupable de les avoir traités
salafistes c'est un nouveau défi contre
l'arrêt
public mais il faut arrêter de céder et
là aussi il faut de la fermeté dans des
moments on fait comment parce que là il
ya toute la procédure qui a été engagée
enfin jean michel blanquer courageux
mais il n'est pas suivi par la majorité
faut le savoir sur ces sujets on a eu un
débat dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale sur dans le dans le cadre du
projet de loi sur l'école qu'il
apportait qu'il a défendue il s'est fait
mettre en minorité
lorsque j'ai réclamé qu'on interdise le
port du voile pour les accompagnants
scolaires pour les parents scolaire dans
les sorties scolaires c'est un grand
débat
luc chatel quand il était ministre de
nicolas sarkozy avait interdit les
signes religieux pour les parents dans
les sorties scolaires parce que l'école
ça doit rester un symbole de laïcité
on l'a pour les élèves bien sûr depuis
la loi votée sous jacques chirac sur
l'interdiction des signes religieux à
l'école
on l'a naturellement pour les
enseignants c'est notre constitution
mais on avait cette zone un peu
intermédiaire pour les parents d'élèves
le ministre était favorable à cette
proposition mais sa majorité
la refusez donc il y a c'est finalement
le signe de fabrique dans marche il y à
ce double langage permanent à l'heure
vous parliez du message des manuels mac
ronde des mots quelquefois je peux me
retrouver dans ce discours mais les
actes ils ne suivent jamais et au final
au nez dans l'immobilisme et au nez dans
une finalement je dirais d'en face à
cette radicalisation
face à la montée de l'islamisme on est
dans une forme de lâcheté son grand
discours il ya la question eric ciotti
du respect de la loi
quand on le voit là vous parlez de jean
michel branquart et de sa majorité mais
est-ce qui a pas un problème aussi entre
les délais déclaration politique de jean
michel blanquer l'application concrète
légal de celle là est ce que vous
changeriez la loi il faut nous avons des
outils pour faire pour faire respecter
la laïcité mais sur certains sujets il
faut aller plus loin je parlais de cette
question des accompagnants scolaires
personnellement je suis pour
l'interdiction des signes religieux dans
un guichet de service public ou à
l'hôpital
il n'est pas normal qu'on aille à
l'hôpital pour exige
et de choisir son médecin pour des
questions religieuses
qu'on aille à l'hôpital voilées qu'on
aille à un guichet de la sécurité
sociale ou dans une administrée aussi de
ce qui arrive au guichet pas seulement
de ceux qui vous accueille 10 km an je
parle des usagers la vida quoique
concrètement il faut on ne pourrait même
pas avoir à soulever à l'ats sans défaut
me dit non absolument pas présentes
accès à la santé est normalement mais
pas voilées qu'elles rentrent dans un
optionnel devra enlever son so lu ment
c'est une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle gelé défendu à
plusieurs reprises c'est une position
qui de ma part et est personnelle et je
l'assumé je crois que la république doit
ériger et des garde-fous contre la
montée de l'islamisme c'est une menace
c'est la menace majeure aujourd'hui on
entend monsieur macron parler du
nationalisme en europe on entend madame
l'oiseau toujours aussi ready c'est pas
s'ériger en rempart la menace est elle
n'est pas là la menace est l'islamisme
cc 150 mille morts depuis le 11
septembre 2001 ces milliers d'attentats
si cette montée de l'islam politique
donc les mots ils ne suffiront pas on a
zéro d un changement à la loi la loi
eric ciotti merci d'avoir un cycle où je
rappelle que vous êtes le député des
alpes-maritimes l'actualité continue sur
bfm et rmc les 8h54